[Musique]
en cette saison des fêtes j'aimerais
dire quelques mots qui n'ont ni queue ni
tête et qui sonne un peu faux
je vous invite à mater meta de meta a
maté ma tête matin dans des tas d'état
certains y verront certainement une
apostrophe une sorte de réponse à un
certain philosophe qui douze mois avant
la vidéo d'aujourd'hui méditer un la
poésie avec poésie mais parce que je
compte faire beaucoup plus fort encore
j'invoque théo de malade mental en
renfort
thür dire ce qui doit être dit voilà un
art qui semble enfreindre un interdit
mais n'est ce pas le propre de l'art de
se contredire au point de défendre l'
interdiction d'interdire interdire n'est
ce pas une forme d'intolérance
n'y at-il pas subjectivité des
préférences ceci dit est ce une raison
de tout tolérer l'intolérance de
l'intolérance est ce justifié
ne faut-il pas des règles pour vivre en
société mais alors ces règles comment
doivent-elles être réglés ceci soulève
des questionnements philosophiques sur
le libre arbitre et les scrutins
politiques nos choix résulte de nombreux
facteurs à la fois at on le choix de
faire quelques choix que ce soit et puis
il ne faut-il pas à choisir comment
choisir sélectionner une méthode pour
sélectionner le scrutin pour élire
ne faut-il pas les lire thür a tranché
si personne n'est là pour trancher
wikipedia liste des règles pour bien
fonctionner wikipedia m dressé toutes
sortes de listes
wikipédia a même une page qui listent
ses listes d'où la question la liste des
listes y étaient listés voilà une
question qu'un logicien aime penser
kantor russell que dole turing tous
l'ont posé des incohérences ont ainsi
été trouvés des bibles d'emad ont ainsi
été ruinée frais que a bien souffert des
autos référence le pauvre a
particulièrement joué de malchance
chances du malchanceux et d'être
malchanceux les chanceux eux ont
tellement de chance d'être chanceux
dit comme ça ça peut paraître être une
évidence mais l'étude de la chance est
devenue une science les chercheurs
l'exploitent pour mieux maîtriser le
hasard les fluctuations statistiques et
les grands écarts
le hasard pose des problèmes de
définition même pour les experts ça
semble affaire d'opinion et sans doute
que la notion de définition doit avant
tout grandement gagné en précision
mais c'est dur de définir ce qu'est
définir débattre de sémantique est à
n'en plus finir
il nous faut souvent parler sans
définition ça n'aide pas à la clarté des
informations
c'est souvent la cause des divergences
d'opinion et ça peut conduire à de
mauvaises décisions
il faut de la charité interprétative et
promouvoir l' écoute bienveillante
attentive il faut qu'on s'entende sur
comment bien de s'écouter il faut
compter sur les bonnes manières de
compter mais aussi enseigné comment bien
enseigner communiqué les manières de
communiquer ainsi pourra-t-on tomber
plus souvent d'accord au moins sur les
causes de nos divers d accord arrêtons
de vouloir que l'autre pense ce que l'on
pense
c'est peu probable qu'ils disent est
parfaite convergence toutefois l'extrême
opposé n'est pas une option
chacun son opinion est une drôle
d'opinion ainsi pour un logiciel tout
n'est pas permis
les axiomes implique forcément des
interdits certaines conclusions sont
alors inévitable certaine opinion donc
un poids négligeable
ceci dit il n'y a pas de logique sans
axiome il y a même bien plus de logique
qu'il n'y paraît pour certaines ce qui
n'est pas faux peut ne pas être vrai en
un sens il n'y a pas de logique autonome
même la logique est une chose dont on
peut douter la logique de la logique est
à méditer
mais comme on l'a vu la logique ne
suffit pas pour connaître le monde il
faut aussi les observez bien le penser
nécessite beaucoup de données mais
attention tous les médias ne se valent
pas les sceptiques nous propose de doute
et avant tout mais si on doute aussi du
doute devient ton fou douter est-ce donc
justifiable mans justifié croire s
injustifiable le mans injustifiée il
faut réfléchir sur comment mieux
réfléchir il faut s'instruire sur les
manières de mieux s'instruire
il faut savoir comment mieux penser le
savoir il faut fonder les fondations de
le savoir
pas facile quand on ne sait pas ce qu'on
ne sait pas au moins sait-on qu'on ne
sait pas tout ce qu'on ne sait pas il
nous faut pour organiser la connaissance
mesurer toute l'étendue de notre
ignorance
il nous faut décrire notre propre
incertitudes et transformer la modestie
en habitude mais même l'incertitude est
pleine d'incertitudes
l'incertitude sur l'incertitude vos
études il faut parler du probable et de
l'improbable
mais même de ce qui est probablement
probable et préparer l'un probablement
improbable mais sans négliger l'un
probablement probable il faut estimer
nos chances de nous faire surprendre
et pour cela il nous faut apprendre à
apprendre et même si c'est étrange il
nous faut nous attendre à voir l'horizon
de notre ignorance s'étendre célébrons
donc l'humilité épistémique que l'erreur
cesse de toujours être en train de
tragique
ceci dit science sans conscience n'est
que ruine de l'âme
pensez juste c'est bien agir pour le
bien c'est mieux
le mieux est l'ennemi du bien et le bien
du mieux agissons au mieux et gare au
retour de flamme
les avant d'agir mieux vaut sans doute
réfléchir dans un brouillard avancée
peut conduire au pire avant de soulever
des massifs montagneux
encore faut-il savoir vraiment ce que
l'on veut il est sans doute crucial de
faire la différence entre ce qu'on dit
vouloir ce que l'on pense vouloir et
surtout ce que l'on voudrait vraiment
vouloir ce dernier semble mériter notre
préférence
donc pour agir au mieux aspirons à
vouloir non pas ce qu'on veut mais ce
qu'on voudrait vouloir aspirons aussi à
bien mieux nous informer et aspirons
également à mieux penser en fait il
semble qu'il fallait avant tout aspiré
voir pour commencer aspirer à aspirer
voilà qui est bien plus facile à dire
qu'à faire les envies de paresse sont
tellement dur à terre il peut être bon
de parfois se faire violence mais bien
faire et bien plus un marathon qu'une
urgence
il est donc peut être mieux de s'auto ne
jay et cherchait pas à pas a sans cesse
progresser c'est sans doute bien mieux
que de toujours s'indigner si ce n'est
s'indigner contre le fait de s'indigner
car l'indignation n'appelle pas bien à
l'action
elle n'est pas franchement source de
motivation les altruistes efficace au
contraire d'expérience préfèrent
davantage miser sur la bienveillance
il aime souvent discuté de progrès moral
le progrès de ce progrès semblent être
capitale il insiste aussi sur la joie
d'être un altruiste l'altruisme gagne à
être une volonté égoïste
le premier pas vers un altruisme plus
efficace semble donc d'intégrer l'assaut
altruisme efficace et puis pour démarrer
l'altruisme dans le futur prendre soin
de son bien-être semble une priorité car
l'altruisme ponctuelles n'a que peu
d'utilité les actions efficaces seront
celles qui perdurent mais toutes les
actions qui perdure ne se valent pas
certaines ont des conséquences
révolutionnaire ses actions deviendront
alors prioritaire
toutefois avant d'en arriver jusque là
il faudra déterminer ses priorités
les identifier et donc une priorité il y
a urgence à identifier les urgences à
identifier les besoins et les carences
puis il faudra promouvoir ces
informations
car une armée d'altruiste sera plus
redoutable à condition d'être guidées
par des faits fiable il faut la
promotion de ce type de promotion
il faudra également prêter attention à
la clarté de tout sensibilisation en
particulier avant même de conseiller
il me faut vos conseils sur comment
conseiller on en revient à bien parler
de bien parler
pour que l'impact du dialogue soit
maximisée en bref ces réflexions sur
meta de meta m'amène surtout à penser
comment mieux penser à la place et aux
lois des probabilités et à poser le
débat sur ce qu'est un bon débat tels
seront les deux grands thèmes de l'année
qui vient
on parlera longuement de raisonnement
bayésiens et on réfléchira à comment
débattre au mieux pour contribuer à
rendre le monde plus merveilleux
un énorme merci latéraux cité royale de
théo est l'un des poètes de ballades
mental si vous ne connaissez pas bah
allez voir ça je vous le promets vous ne
le regretterez pas avant de vous
abandonner à votre champagne je tiens à
vous dire un merci du fond du coeur 2018
a été remplie de bonheur entre le
panthéon la sorbonne et la montagne
et puis bien sûr les axiomes avec
monsieur fille et il ya aussi ce gros
pavé qui est sorti grâce à votre soutien
je suis passé sur son cv rts le monde
france culture string theory s
d'assurance palais de la découverte
station f polytechnique hoeness et la
fff à essaouira montréal ou montpellier
et tout ça c'est grâce à vous tous qui
me suivait donc je vous dis merci merci
et encore merci j'ai une chance inouïe
de vous avoir ici sur ce joyeux noël et
bonne nouvelle année et préparez vous à
être taillés ziani zay
[Musique]
s'il est pour m'avoir fait des noeuds au
cerveau